Film Courage: Why do so many writers say that
outlining prevents them from being creative?
Naomi Beaty, Writer, Screenwriting Teacher and
Consultant: I think a lot of writers feel if they
outline to in too detailed of a manner it will
force them into a corner when they're writing
they'll have it too planned out it'll take the
creativity out of it it'll take that spontaneity
out of their creative process or something that
I I guess that's my that's my best guess that's
why some writers think that that outlining is
stifling but I actually think that outlining
the the process of outlining your story breaking
your story and and forming the outline can be the
creative process that creative process that you
look for when you're writing of Discovery and
coming up with new ideas by juxtaposing things
that you didn't expect or whatever you can do
that in the outlining process itself and have
all of those Sparks of inspiration and creativity
while you're working in that in that format
instead of in on the page if that makes sense
do you get a lot of pushback from
writers who don't want to outline
not a ton I I think it's probably 50 50 in terms
of writers who liked outline or at least have
learned that it's more helpful than than painful
for them and so there are plenty of writers who
Embrace outlining as part of their process and
they're but then there are also writers who either
feel it's too stifling or don't really have a
good process and so they stay away from outlining
or avoid it just because they don't really
have a set of steps that they can go through
that's reliably helps them plan out their story
some writers consider themselves very intuitive
writers and they're their their pantsers instead
of plotters I don't think that even those writers
that consider themselves intuitive writers I
don't think that I get a lot of pushback from them
usually those writers if they've been through a
few writing projects and it's been a struggle to
get all the way through because they haven't
had a map to guide them through it an outline
they are usually not pushing back on needing
an outline they're coming to me because they're
okay I don't really love the outlining
process but I feel I need one in order to
help me get through the draft so more than
anything they're coming to me and saying I
want to learn a little bit about outlining
that I can maybe incorporate into my more
free-form process but that will give me some
structure to help me get through the writing
and you think when we tell a writer that this
outlining is so much part of the process and
really if you don't have one it's building a
house without a good set of blueprints that it's
pulling back this this magical curtain that they
thought it was just going to be this free-flowing
thing and it's almost disappointing in some way I
hope it's not disappointing but yeah I think that
maybe maybe coming up with a story in the
outlining process to some writers feels it's
it's going to be too Technical and too rigid but
but if you actually start because outlining can
mean so many different things to so many different
writers so if you actually start working through
different steps different tools different types
of processes to get get through an outline you'll
see that it's really adaptable it's the process
of outlining is whatever you make of it it's
whatever helps you prepare to write whatever it is
you're writing so I don't know I don't think it's
I don't think it's necessarily disappointing to
writers but I think that it's maybe eye-opening
they they figure out what outlining really is and
and what it is is specific to them it's whatever's
going to help you plan enough that you have
that structure to get through writing your draft
burden or is part of the process part of the
process for sure I hope that writers don't think
of it as a burden because I actually think that
the outlining process is where a lot of the fun
and creativity can happen it's where you have the
joy of exploring and discovering your story and
figuring out a lot of the fun stuff about it so
I hope it doesn't feel a burden I do think that
whatever prep you do for your story is part of
your own personal process and whether you are a
very detailed outliner or more of just a broad
broad Strokes I got to figure out the general
shape of my story I consider all of that the
pre-writing or outlining process so whatever it
is for you is is part of the process for you why
is it hard for writers who think they have a great
idea to actually start writing their ideas down
and begin the writing process it's a good question
I'm sure there are a lot of different answers
to this question just depending on the writer
I think part of it is probably fear and that fear
can also be different for different writers too
before you write anything down I think an idea
Can Feel Complete and perfect in your head and
then when you sit down to start actually breaking
it down or planning it you can it can be a little
surprising at how little you actually know
about the idea before you started to try to
write it down it felt very complete and perfect
and then when you start to write it sometimes it
it can or start to plan it it can feel Oh I
thought I had more of this figured out or I
thought this idea was a little bit more solid
or complete so I think that can be scary and
can discourage people from beginning the process
because they feel they want to figure out more of
it in their head still before they start putting
anything on paper I actually think putting it on
paper is what helps you work through that
and and helps you figure out your story
so I would encourage people to go ahead and
just start but but yeah I think it's probably
fear something can feel very solid and makes
sense before you have to articulate it and
then when you try to articulate it it ends up
showing the holes in it so do you think it's
because a lot of writers or quote-unquote artists
in general live in their heads so much and and it
feels so real to them the story and then when
you actually say okay let's actually see it on
the and and then it's it's you're you're asking
them to be in reality yeah I'm sure that there
is truth to that because so many writers are
living in their imaginations a lot of the time
I also think that a lot of times when we get
inspired by a story idea we get really excited
about it what we're thinking about most of the
time is that Act One setup portion of it it's the
interesting situation that funny what if or what
it how would this happen or why would this happen
and then when you sit down to figure out the
whole story you realize oh the part that got
me so excited and there's nothing wrong with it
at all but the the part that gets us excited is
that setup it's that situation that interesting
what if and then the rest of the story is the
part that you still have to figure out so I think
that that it's not that you it's not that you came
up with an idea that you thought was better than
it actually is it's that you came up with an idea
that you have only partially figured out as is
natural because you came up with that part first
and then the work of it is figuring out the rest
of the story The the journey that your character
is going to go on so I think that's what I was
feeling I just didn't know how to put it into
words and I think that that was that's it it's
that's the the setup is so vivid in our minds but
then actually having it pay off and there'd be an
arc yes and and a resolution to it I think that's
yeah yeah yeah because that's usually that's
that spark of inspiration is we get inspired by
that oh wouldn't it be funny if this happened or
wouldn't it be dramatic or scary if this happened
and that's all that act one setup stuff so what
is your argument for writers to learn an outlining
process that works for them hmm my argument for
it let's see well I mean I I think that having
a process will help you having something to fall
back on when you feel stuck or you feel frustrated
or you feel I thought I had the story all figured
out and now I'm realizing it's only the beginning
having a process that you have worked through
before that it works for you or at least that
you have some tools to draw on that can help you
get unstuck I think that's helpful helpful for any
writer and no matter your experience level I think
with every project there's going to be a point
where you do get stuck or you feel frustrated
or it's not going as well as you wanted it to
or you thought it would so just having that tool
kit which is what I think of as a as an outlining
process I think of it as just a toolkit a bunch of
tools that you how to use and you can draw on them
when you need them to help you keep progressing
through the through the process but say I hire you
and I have this great screenplay and I just know
this is going to be this is going to transform
people's lives once it's on the screen and I
keep showing you draft after draft and your note
to me is I think we need an outline and I'm the
stubborn writer and I say no it's going to ruin
it and I what what's a tough love way to be my
accountability partner and say I really think we
need to go back and and flesh this out more yeah
that's I mean that's a good question and I and I
have worked with writers who who were a little bit
resistant to making big changes or or something
that after a few drafts most writers feel okay I'm
tired of of working through the whole draft so I
think the best argument for outlining if you're
in that situation is you can work on the story in
an outline form which is much smaller and shorter
and easier to manage than working on your entire
draft trying to go into your screenplay pages
and make changes sometimes is very difficult
it's you're you're adjusting things in the in
the living document of it versus if you make
an outline even of an existing draft make your
changes in that document that's looking at the
skeleton of the screenplay so you can move things
around more easily you're not looking at completed
scenes that you've already fallen in love with or
lines of dialogue that you love and you don't want
to change you're looking at it from a little bit
more I think maybe of an objective point of view
you're looking less at the on the page stuff and
looking at the skeleton of your story which I
think helps people have some perspective on it
and be able to see what's not working and make
changes without getting bogged down in in all
the stuff that all the work they've already put
into it that they don't want to redo I love that
so fatigue I you use that word and so if you're
seeing a fatigued writer and let's suppose I'm
this again I'm resistant no Neil we've got to
do it this way it's fantastic and then you're
seeing the fatigue on this side that that does
sound interesting then let's look at it and
let's try to actually just shorten it down
and then work out the problems yeah and a lot
of times when I'm working with writers I will
actually outline I will make an outline from their
draft so that I can talk about it in a way that is
has that perspective and I can say okay so if we
look at act one and see here are all the scenes
this is this is the issue that we're trying to
address let's look at which scenes that might be
happening in or which scenes might be missing that
so we're not getting the information we need or
or whatever the the specific issue is oh I love
that it's almost the analogy of let's suppose I
have this messy closet and I can't find anything
in it and then you come and you're this organizer
and you're okay let's put all of the blouses and
I that that's beautiful that's a good analogy yeah
but this somebody that that has that skill
of being able to see the big picture and yeah
yeah and I do think too we get so attached to
the things that we're writing our scripts and
our projects and everything that I think that
sometimes it's easier to have me outline it
from their draft versus for a couple of
reasons sometimes writers because they've
written a whole draft they're well I don't
want to go back and outline it now I don't
want to make an outline from the thing I've
already written what good is that gonna do me
so sometimes they're resistant to do it at all but
I also think that sometimes it's easier for me to
do it again because I'm I'm objectively looking
at the script so I can look at the scene and say
well here's what I'm getting from the scene that's
what I'm going to write down in the outline versus
if you're very close to your story what you
were trying to get across in that scene and
so you might outline it differently than I would
as well so sometimes it's helpful I think if I do
the outline or if we compare outlines and then we
can see where's the discrepancy here oh this is
what that scene was meant to do from your point of
view and here's what I think it's actually doing
why do you say that most movie ideas are very
simple well I think movies tend to be based on
really simple stories one of the things that newer
writers can end up doing without realizing it is
over complicating their stories because they feel
especially if they start writing without a solid
outline and they get stuck they feel oh I have
to add more complications to give me more story
to write and they'll end up making things overly
complex where the movies that we tend to see are
pretty straightforward stories they're a concise
setup some good escalations in the middle and
then wrap it up in the end and it's the execution
that makes things entertaining and interesting so
it's it's not that we need very complex stories in
movies a lot of times overly complex stories will
be hard to follow a little bit bloated it'll be
hard to really go deep in a character's experience
in a story that has too many complications or
too many characters whereas typically in movies
what we see is one person pursuing one thing and
what's interesting or entertaining about it is the
way that that is executed the interesting
cinematic cool stuff that happens along
that Journey which is actually a pretty simple
Journey but it allows us the space to dive into
how that character is transforming the emotional
experience of it and the the cool cinematic stuff
that happens along the way does a simple idea
mean a boring screenplay no I I don't think so
I think most if you look at most movies it's
actually a very simple storyline it's a it's
a pretty straightforward one person trying to
achieve one thing I think a lot of times newer
writers maybe worry that their stories are
too simple and that will make them boring but
if you have a simple story that just gives you a a
nice sturdy framework to tell your story and then
it gives you the space and the freedom to find
the entertaining moments and cool stuff in the
execution of that story if that makes sense and no
you've said and I don't know if it was it was in
the book or it's in an interview that the cliche
of the the pretty but doesn't know it or the hot
mess that is rescued that that's been done so much
and I agree but what if somebody really needs to
stick to the rom-com where High School reunion
and best friends getting married and does anybody
object but they want to do the next Memento or
they want to do the next crash something that
takes a little more putting together and you
guide them and say maybe you're not totally
ready for that yet yeah I think that that is a
challenge some there are some stories that are
I don't know if I would call them more complex but
the the execution of them is more advanced crashes
intersecting storylines all put together
within the structure of a feature film
I would call that in a advanced craft movie so
I don't think that that's necessarily an overly
complicated story at all and there definitely
are newer writers who who love movies that and
who want to write something that and that's what's
inspiring them and getting them in front of the
computer to write it I certainly wouldn't
discourage them I do think that when you're
learning it's going to be easier to learn and to
to understand to wrap your brain around how to put
a screenplay together if you work with a simpler
story or a more straightforward mainstream story
with one main character who's pursuing one main
goal in the story that'll be easier just to learn
on if that makes sense when you're learning to
drive a car if you learn on an automatic that's a
little bit easier than learning how to shift and
learning how to drive at the same time not that
it can't be done but it just might take a little
bit longer it might take a little more patience
so so yeah I think that if you're if you have
the desire to write something crash or memento
if you are willing to be patient with yourself and
give yourself the time to figure out how to write
that particular screenplay then great different
people are motivated by different things so if
that's what's going to get you to show up and keep
trying and keep learning your craft then go for it
it just know that it might be a longer process
because you're learning lots of different skill
sets at the same time and learning how to write a
screenplay is already a bunch of different skill
sets put together so that's just adding a little
bit more to your plate but it it can be done for
sure sure I love that analogy so the driving
the car so it's learning to drive in your dad's
old Station Wagon versus some sporty little
foreign model with a clutch on a hill right
exactly and you've never driven before and
you have all these people behind you honking
so yeah that that makes sense yeah yeah but if
you're in that situation I mean if that's what
inspires you to learn how to drive then then go
for it and just know that you have you're going to
have to be gentle on yourself and and patient with
yourself because it's it's probably going to be
frustrating but if you love the story that's okay
you might have the patience to get through that
do you think audiences though really
resonate more with simple stories or
no as long as it's a well-told story yeah
I think as long as it's a well-told story
I think simple stories the the benefit that that
maybe they offer to audiences and to writers too
is that they when I say A Simple Story I mean
the the plot framework is fairly straightforward
and what you're what you're able to bring to that
as a writer is finding new ways that maybe the
tropes that we expect from the genre those things
are executed in a new interesting entertaining
cinematic way so you're bringing your you're
not you're not writing the boring screenplay
just to make it easy for yourself you're you're
choosing a story that gives you a framework
that is easy to wrap your brain around so that
you can bring the creativity to it and add the
entertaining stuff on top of it and then the
other benefit is that with a with a somewhat
straightforward plot I don't want to say it's
too straightforward but if with a simple plot
framework that allows you to then come up with
the cool reversals and interesting twists and
turns and all that stuff the other thing that
you can that that gives you is the space and
the freedom to develop the character more because
if you are taking less time time to explain the
way the plot is working or why complications are
happening the way they are it gives you room for
the characters to feel things and to interact with
each other and to transform and be be affected by
what they're going through and it gives you some
space for us to have that experience along with
the character if that makes sense it does and
I know we've talked about bridesmaids before
and you use it as an example in the book and what
seems a simple story when you actually put these
relationship Dynamics it's actually much more
complicated and yeah very interesting yeah and
that's a good example I think that bridesmaids is
a simple story it's a very clear story framework
that that they're working within but they have
all these lovely lovely funny set pieces that are
inventive that we haven't seen before so that's
in the execution that they're able to they have
this sturdy Foundation that they're building
on top of but it gives them the freedom to do
really fun funny entertaining things and we also
because the plot framework is so sturdy and easy
for us to understand what's happening you get that
character that is nicely developed over the entire
movie which you might not expect that in a broad
comedy but there's a lot of feeling there too
she's really going through something in that story
so yeah there's a lot of levels and and it's about
to the outward appearances yeah and and trying
to keep up with friendships and your peer group
and stuff and and so yeah it's a movie that when
I first heard about it I was yeah that's not for
me and everybody was oh you got to see bridesmaids
I'm no and then I finally saw it and I'm why was
I resistant to it because it's excellent yeah
that's one of those I can watch over and over
again because it's so entertaining and there
is so much genuine Humanity in it as well so
if a writer has three ideas how do
they know which one to choose oh well
I think it depends on what they want out of the
writing project so there I think there are a
few criteria you can look to and it's a really
personal decision I also think you don't ever
have to throw an idea away if you have three that
you want to write that means you're really just
choosing which one you're going to write next and
then you can always have the other two on Deck
I personally think that you should gauge
the concept and make sure that each idea
you're weighing is a strong enough idea
to be a screenplay that's the first thing
but if all that's equal I think you you should
look at what you want to get out of the out of
the project so is it helping you learn a new skill
in your in your writing toolkit is it helping you
advance your career in a particular way is it
filling out your portfolio of writing samples
so that is helpful to to gauge what do I
want this to do for me so that you're not
no writing is wasted it's not wasted time but
so that you're getting the most out of of the
project that you're going to write and then also
if the ending I think that that's very helpful
because that sometimes if you start a
writing project without knowing the ending
that can be a longer more frustrating process
to to outline that but if you how this story
ends the outlining of it the figuring out how
the the plot progresses all the steps in the
plot and everything that's a little bit easier
because what destination you're headed towards
so that's interesting when you said that you've
you've actually outlined four people once you
see their finished script if you see someone
who's hung up on the ending do you get them
to that point and then say okay now I mean I
realize you're not figuring out the ending for
them but do do you outline up until that point
and then maybe that helps them through it well
if I'm if I'm making an outline from a finished
draft that someone's given me to read I outline
exactly what they have in the draft so if their
ending isn't working or if it isn't complete
and I have read scripts that I will outline
exactly what they have and then we'll talk about
what's missing here is it is that the ending is
totally gone and you need to figure out what that
is or is it just that you've you've wrapped up
the plot but it's not it's really not complete or
resolving things as it needs to so I mean that's
just a normal a normal day in in doing the script
consults is lot of times the ending needs work so
we'll just talk about how can we strengthen that
sure but that sounds really helpful just again as
it's easier for someone to come in and organize
someone's space than if you have all these
personal mementos and oh I can't get rid of
this I can't get rid of that oh my grandmother
gave me this but if the organizer comes in and
says how about we put this over here it yeah it
sounds it's much easier yeah and I think that
I think that that's such a good analogy because
that is probably what it feels as well if you've
written a draft and you're here are the scenes
that I love and I want them to be in there but
something about it isn't working there is that
feeling of I'm attached to these things but I
don't know how to organize them in a way that they
need to in order for it to make sense for everyone
else as well sure yeah sure and then you open the
closet door everything falls yes and hence the
screenplay might be really jumbled and if we put
it if we make sense to the to the the viewer or
the reader yeah yeah and when when I go in there
it's I can outline based on what they already have
have and then we can talk about okay so here's
what we have so far and then here's what the third
act needs to do here's how it needs to resolve the
plot and wrap up character Arc and all that stuff
so what are we missing and then we can fill in the
holes what is brain dump oh that's just something
I'm sure other people use it in different ways
but it's something that I think is a useful
exercise to do at the beginning of your your story
breaking process when you come up with an idea
and you haven't really done much to shape it
yet I think it's really useful to just sit down
and write down everything about that idea because
you end up capturing stuff that you maybe didn't
realize you knew about it or thought about it and
then you also end up capturing what you love about
that idea when you're in that moment of still
being in love with it so that later on when you're
writing the script and you inevitably get to that
frustrating part where you get stuck or you don't
know what happens next and you are feeling why did
I start writing this you can go back to that brain
dump and remember what made me fall in love with
this idea to begin with or what was it about this
idea that in spite hired me how did I want people
to feel what were my hopes and aspirations for
this project before I went down started Down
The Long Road of actually writing it so yeah
so if I have let's say a notebook and it's my idea
for this movie or this character I'm just this is
my notebook where I'm going to put The Good the
Bad and the Ugly about this character the story
anything I can think of yeah and I think it's
probably different for every project and for every
writer what comes to mind I think it's useful
to give yourself a little bit of structure some
parameters around the brain dump but really it
should be whatever about your your project at that
point in time so I just think write down anything
that where the idea came from anything that
inspires you about the idea or how do you see this
finished movie what other movies would it would
would it be what's the soundtrack sound are there
any songs that give you that feeling that you want
the movie to have talking about characters for
sure who's the main character if that what's that
character what relationships does that character
have who are the people in his or her life
anything that you come to the table with
when you're just getting inspired by that
idea just starting to gather everything that
about it that you're going to start shaping
into the story eventually because at the
beginning it's you have a jumble of ideas
I think you have oh this would be a great
scene or oh I think it ends this maybe with
this final shot I don't know how we get there
but it's them riding off into the sunset or
I I don't know who this character is but I think
that there's a guy who had this background or has
this affectation and I wonder how he got to
be that way and so it's just a it's just a
way for you to start to gather all of those little
tidbits that you think might belong to this story
put them all in one place so that you don't have
that that feeling of that nervous feeling of I'm
gonna forget this idea and I I don't know where
it goes yet and so you're all stressed out about
trying to work it into the story you can put it
all in one place and just hold it there so that
as you're working through that development process
you can always go back to it and reference it come
up with those ideas that you had at one time that
maybe you'd forgotten about so so let's suppose I
was Eric Roth and I was thought of this idea for
this Forrest Gump character or based on a book
whatever and and I thought okay here's my here's
my notebook with forest in it and so southern town
loving mom definitely health problems with with
his legs different things and then meets Jenny
meets Bubba all these different things
meets Captain Dan you know different
fights different things and his goal of being
this just this theme through his life of of
being in these interesting places at the time
and helping people he's almost a helper yeah
and so I'm just getting it out this is Forest
this is there wasn't really anything bad about
him but these are some of the things that that
make up this Forest character yeah and hopefully
if you're working on that project or you were
inspired enough to sit down and start to gather
your thoughts hopefully there's something about
who that character is that you really or that
interests you at least and so so those are
the things that I think you should focus on
because those are going to be the things that
help you later on in the story having those
touchstones of oh yeah I remember I really
wanted this character to have this particular
feeling or to maybe have this particular
Arc to learn this lesson across this story
so yeah I I don't even know if you I guess if
that much about your story it's great and write
it all down but you don't even have to try
to shape it in the brain dump process I think
I wouldn't put pressure on yourself to try to
come up with oh this is First Act stuff and
this is where the story goes from there it's just
whatever whatever Sparks your interest when you
think about that particular idea and I always the
the prompts or questions you ask yourself about
what do how do I see this in its finished form
even if it's not specifics but it's how do I want
people to feel when they see it or what does the
soundtrack sound is a good one because it's What
feelings does it give you when you hear the music
or what music makes you think of this idea or
make you feel the way this idea makes you feel and
then I also one other thing that I think is really
helpful to do in the brain dump process is think
about what the story means to you because that
helps you start to narrow in on the theme of the
story which I think is one of those things that
really intimidates a lot of writers it feels oh I
have to come up with some big profound statement
but really you're just trying to come up with the
mean what does it mean to you what's the takeaway
message or big idea that this story imparts and
that can be really daunting and intimidating so
if you do it in the brain dump process where
you're just free-flowing and brainstorming
it gives you a pressure free and environment to
think about what does the story mean what lesson
would this character learn or what lesson could
this experience teach someone and what's the story
about for me what does it what does it mean to me
inside that I that I want to get at or explore in
the story okay so I wouldn't necessarily know
maybe all of these things when I mentioned
Lieutenant Dan and these things I would just know
that it's a character maybe the odds were stacked
against him but he didn't really have a mean
streak in him he didn't need to get revenge on
people yeah or maybe what have been done to him or
or he was still just a kind-hearted guy yeah and
I think maybe if you were developing that story
idea in the brain dump process you might not know
the specifics about those other characters but you
might say okay I have this main character that I'm
really interested in I think his name's Forrest
Gump and he's this type of guy he's a he's such
a kind person he doesn't have a mean bone in his
body and the kinds of people that he could run
into that would create conflict and help him
move through the story might be someone who
he's in love with who doesn't reciprocate and
so he has to contend with that set of emotions
maybe he has a mentor character that he meets
in the unlikely place of in the in the military
it's been a long time since I saw so I don't
remember if Dan is the mentor but maybe he meets
somebody who's very Gruff and the opposite of him
personality wise maybe he meets Bubba who in some
ways is similar innocent and sees the world
in a particular way and so by pairing up with
that person these are the kinds of things that he
might experience or lessons that he might learn or
situations he might find himself in you believe
most movies can come down to three words who
wants what yeah I think that that's the the basic
nut of of any movie is you have a main character
who is trying to achieve something because if you
don't have those basic elements and that's not the
whole story obviously but if you don't have those
basic elements then then really what is the story
you don't have a character to be our vehicle
through a series of events and you don't have
anything propelling them forward or driving them
forward if they're not trying to achieve something
so if we just think we have this interesting
character and all these different things happen
to them and these cool conflict situations but we
don't actually know what does this character want
is that something that we really have to do a lot
of soul searching is this are we that character
do we have to see is this us yeah well I mean
I do think the characters should always be our
mirror or our vehicle through the story but when
I say who wants what I'm actually talking about
more external plot stuff because that's what's
going to give you that that plot framework to
tell your story so really the who wants what is
is figuring out what external plot thing or what
destination is your protagonist aiming toward
through this story knowing that helps you plan the
story and write it but it also indicating that to
the audience is really helpful because that's how
we track where we are in the story if we know what
that character is trying to achieve that gives
us a yardstick to measure is he succeeding or is
he failing is he making progress or is he having
setbacks and that's the that's that put push-pull
of hope and fear that we have when we're watching
the movie is we're hoping that he makes progress
and gets to his destination but we're fearing the
worst we're fearing all these obstacles are going
to derail him or end up damaging him in some way
so that's what I really mean when I when I say
who wants what we need to know who are we watching
in the story whose story is it and what are they
trying to achieve from an external plot point of
view because that gives us that spine of the story
or that through line that we're tracking over the
course of the movie what distinguishes the main
character from all other characters in a film
the writer has decided that that's
the main character no I think that
to some degree that's that is true you decide
who whose story you're telling and then what
separates that character in the screenplay or for
the audience is the focus that you place on that
character you want to tell the story from that
character's perspective or from their point of
view so that we know who we're watching go through
this set of experiences so what separates the
protagonist from the other characters is really
the focus that you place on them and how you tell
the story through the lens of their experience
does that make sense it does yeah I just saw a
Crazy Stupid Love oh yeah for the first time and
it came out 2011 or whatever did you enjoy it I
did I love and again it was one not one that
I would normally think I would love but Steve
Carell he's a good guy you want to root for him
and then he meets the Dark Horse who then you find
out is really not that dark once you get to know
him but it you it takes you on this this journey
but a lot of the side characters are also very
complicated and complex yeah I actually that's a
great example I just rewatched it and I had a new
appreciation for it watching it again I remembered
really liking it and finding it funny but watching
it over again already knowing where the story was
going I could pay a little bit more attention
to how it was put together and you're it's it's
pretty much a true Ensemble because so many Side
characters get their own story lines and it has
these intersecting story lines but I do think
Steve Carell is the protagonist in that story
even though he in act two we spend a lot of
time we go away from him and shift Focus to
the Ryan Gosling character so just page count
wise you might not be able to decide who is
the main character they both get their screen
time but I think what makes Steve Carell the
character the protagonist there is that first
of all the way the story starts we get into it
through him wanting to know what his story is and
and getting on board with his experience through
the story and then he also wraps it up in the end
he's the one who learns the lesson and brings that
lesson to the group and has his transformational
experience and and we're rooting for him I think
the whole time so sure sure but you're there are
so many because it's not just it's not just Ryan
Gosling it's the Emma Stone character it's the
babysitter it's all these different ones and they
all have these interesting plights that they're
dealing with yeah that the Kevin Bacon character
and and and you see all of their why they did what
they did from these different things but you still
in the end you root for the Steve Carell or at
least yeah yes viewers would yeah and it's so
it does such a good job of not making anyone the
villain as well which I thought was really fun
and yeah and and you're you're it's a great
one yeah it is it is again it's one that
simple concept but then when you take all the
relationship Dynamics and all the little nuances
and stuff it's yeah it's quite that one's again
not probably an easy one to write yeah were you
surprised by the the way it all comes together
I was okay yeah I definitely was I was too and I
thought that they did such a good job of making
that feel believable but also it it's big it's
over the top and you're oh it's it's for humor's
sake the way things come together I don't want to
spoil it sure even though it's over a decade old
but we'll keep 30 years for spoilers yeah yeah
but it's so entertaining the way all the story
lines intersect and you don't see it coming but
then it all makes perfect sense the way it unfolds
that so yeah what makes an effective protagonist
a few different things I think that primarily
they have to be able to drive the action of the
plot you need a protagonist who can take action
who's willing to take action or at least can
be convinced to take action otherwise your plot
won't advance if he's not he or she isn't doing
something to pursue their goal and then I also
think that they're on the on the character side
of things there are certain things that we look
for in a protagonist to help us get on board with
them to help us align with them and be willing
to go through the story with them so there's the
the cliche thing and the thing that writers hate
to hear is that making your protagonist likeable
but there's some truth to that even if your
character isn't likable I think they do need to
be someone that we're willing to go along on this
journey with so they have to be at least engaging
and entertaining enough for us to to dislike
them sure so yeah so I think those two they're
two prongs of that question which is what makes
an effective protagonist plot wise in the story
it has to be someone who can take action and who
can who can do things that move the plot forward
and then on the character development side of
things it's someone that we're willing to go
along with as they go through this story now I
think even Stephen King said in on writing that
he didn't really the character of Carrie which
I actually her but I I think that he felt that
she was compelling enough and real enough and
he saw some similarities in his town yeah and
so yeah I mean to invest that much time in a
character that you don't think is actually that
likable but other people saw there's something
here yeah and I think there's even if you don't
it's been a while since I read Carrie but I
think even if you don't that character even if
it's not someone that you would hang out with
he does a really good job of creating empathy
for that character it's she's in a terrible
situation she's being bullied at home and
at school and she's awkward and doesn't fit in
and that of course is going to even if we don't
her in a traditional sense I think we feel for
her and and that's enough to get us on board
and to want to know what she's going to do next
because that's an interesting theory of wanting
to spend time with a character that we don't
actually we maybe if we met them in real life
we wouldn't actually want to sit next to them at
the school lunch table I mean that's yeah no and I
can think of plenty of people that I wouldn't want
to but would I want to invest time in a story from
that character's point of view I guess I guess
because if we could try to find something that
we could somehow connect with yeah and that's
that whole if you walk a mile in a man's shoes
you'll understand what they're going through
and even if you don't agree with them you can
empathize you can understand actually to bring
it back to the Crazy Stupid Love I feel that
was another thing that that movie did really well
even if so none of those characters are unlikable
but they did such a good job of making us care
about and empathize with Steve Carell in the
beginning so that he could then go on and become
this cad-like divorce guy so he's he becomes a
womanizer for a short time in in the film and
I think that could turn a lot of people off but
because they spent time in the beginning making
us care about him and feel bad for him because his
wife asks for a divorce in a crowded restaurant
out of the blue that gets us that earns enough of
our our love for him that we can we know why he's
doing what he's doing and we can watch him do some
not great stuff for a little while before he he
brings it back around and redeems himself and we
see a lot of what he's he's being groomed by this
other guy yeah who he doesn't get it even from
the genes and the and that he's turn around you
have a mom butt these are not those are not the
jeans for you yes yeah and so yeah he reluctantly
goes into that womanizer phase he thinks wearing
these tennis shoes and these Dad jeans are okay
but because that's not he wasn't really setting
out to be that person so I think you see that he's
actually a good guy yeah and he's doing it out of
and then when you see the other and I hope I'm not
giving a spoiler away but the other divorce dad in
the bar sipping on the drink and he doesn't really
have much of a role but you're oh that's the next
incarnation of him yeah that's you want you want
Steve Carell to avoid becoming that guy no matter
if you don't agree with what he's doing now why
he's doing it sure you feel for him you want
him to not be lonely and sad so you're willing for
him to to be you said be groomed in that direction
even if it's maybe not the greatest Direction
Naomi can you explain what a story goal is sure
the way I use it is really just that it's that
ultimate goal that you're your whole story is
structured around so it's the thing that your
protagonist is trying to achieve in the story
Story Goes just the easiest way to describe it
but it's that it's in Silence of the Lambs it's
Clarice trying to catch the serial killer
Buffalo Bill that's her story goal it's the
plot thing that gives your entire story its
structure is the story goal also the story engine
well the character's pursuit of that story
goal I think is what creates the engine and
the story so the protagonist trying to achieve
that thing that's what drives the story forward
it's what moves the plot so yeah I think the
story goal is a necessary part of that engine
can you give us examples of story goals that work
well so effective ones and then ones that don't
work well sure so effective story goals will have
some external component so they can be dramatized
on screen in some way ineffective story goals are
are usually very internal and things that we can't
see a character taking action toward we can't see
them pursuing if you're writing a movie it's it's
going to be easier to to write it to structure
it if there's some external action or at least
a way for you to show us what the character is
doing and for us to understand what they're doing
let's see another thing that makes a story
goal effective is if it's difficult enough
to achieve that it will take the whole movie
to achieve you don't want something so easy
or so quick that it would be achieved in one
scene or a couple of scenes because you need
it to be difficult enough that your character can
try to can attempt to achieve it over 100 minutes
or whatever and that difficulty can come from the
goal itself can be difficult or it can also come
from there's just so much conflict in the way that
your your characters has a hard time achieving it
because there's something or someone trying to
stop them if that does that make sense it does
so an internal goal is hard because we unless it's
a novel we can't really tell what's going on with
the character yeah and I think that yeah so in a
something that's very internal would be hard for
you to would probably be difficult to show on
screen unless you can find a way to dramatize
it externally I think the movie Short Term 12 is a
good example of that the the story goal is I think
it's twofold in that movie but part of it is one
of the things that the character is going through
is trying to open up to be more open emotionally
which seems it would be hard to to show on screen
how do you show someone struggling with that but
I think they do a good job of of really clearly
saying that it's it's if she can talk about what
happened to her in the past I think that's how the
story goes if she can talk about what happened to
her to her in the past to her fiance then that's
the the the Milestone or The Benchmark that we're
looking for to indicate that she has achieved that
goal so yeah if it's a very internal thing if you
can find a way to indicate that that it's being
pursued and that it's been achieved then you
can that's dramatizing it you can make it and
something that you can shape your movie around
and I think some actors are are really fantastic
at showing a very closed off person I mean William
Hurt was always great at playing somebody that you
could tell there was a lot going on inside but
he wasn't letting it out probably would at some
midpoint but very contained and stifled and
and so I think there's certain certain actors
that really can play to that character yeah and
I think even with that though you something that
something if my goal is to learn how to open up to
other people there are great actors who can play
that struggle of I really want to open up but
I'm afraid to or I can't bring myself to do it
even that can only sustain I think so many scenes
and so it has to be something that you can also
have other characters create conflict with that
with your protagonist there has to be there have
to be obstacles in their way or opposing forces
that are making this difficult for them as well if
that if that makes sense why do you recommend the
writer to find the goal and the method separately
oh well I think that that makes it easier to wrap
your head around your your own story sometimes
because the goal the story goal that thing that
the protagonist is ultimately trying to achieve
it doesn't always imply or indicate the action
that your protagonist will be taking for most of
the movie so I think hell or high water is a good
example of this I don't know if you've seen that
movie or we can talk about Silence of the Lambs
as well whatever one yeah yeah that's okay the
the goal sometimes is a very definite end point
that your character is working towards which is
great because that gives you the framework
for your story and again it gives you that
the thing that your audience is tracking so we
know where the character is headed and that allows
us to understand are they making progress are
they having setbacks but the method I think is
is the missing piece sometimes if you're trying to
break down your story and figure out what happens
moment to moment because sometimes the the method
is different or or not in implied by the story
goal itself and then a lot of times the method
is actually the entertaining thing about the
story it's the thing that people want to see in
the movie so I know these are examples that that
are foreign to you but Silence of the Lambs her
goal is to catch the serial killer but the method
she's using is working with Hannibal Lecter which
is fascinating sure that relationship is part of
the the entertainment hook of the of the movie so
that's what we're excited to watch it's also the
Chase and trying to catch that serial killer but
the the really the scenes that everyone remembers
are the ones where she's dealing with Hannibal
Lecter and going toe-to-toe with him mentally
and matching wits with him and he's baiting her
and showing that he's got the upper hand right
and he's pushing her in ways that other people
don't push her and forcing her to figure out
that she's she can she can handle it and she can
do it and she can catch the serial killer it's a
great relationship another example hell or high
water just really quickly since I brought it up
his ultimate goal is to get the I think
it's forty thousand dollars to the bank by
such whatever the deadline is that's the ultimate
goal that's what he's working towards over the
course of the movie but the method that he's
using is he has a plan to rob a series of small
town Texas Banks so that again that's where the
entertainment value comes from whereas we're
watching him pull off this carefully planned
series of Bank heists in small Texas towns
that's entertaining and that if you were writing
that movie and you just knew okay this guy needs
to get this money to the bank on time that gives
you the big picture framework but it's helpful
for you the writer to figure out okay but what's
the what's the method what's the more specific
method that he's using to do that because then
that gives you that act 2 action that you can
go oh okay so he's going to do it by coming
up with this plan to Rob all these banks in
quick succession okay how's he going to do that
how many would you have to do in a day and it
it gives you more to work with when you're coming
up with the scene by scene plotting of your story
why don't we ever hear about writing a story and
coming up with a goal first it seems all we do
is just want to come up with this character and
we're as you say we're really in love with the
First Act but the actual story goal it seems fall
short for many new writers or no do you think so
I'm not sure I I feel you can come at a story from
a lot of different ways and no matter which angle
you you come to that idea from no matter which
aspect of it inspired you to want to write it you
still have to fill in all of the other elements
in order to have a complete thing that can work
I wonder if I wonder if it feels that way
because a lot of times the story goal feels
dry plot very plot specific and dry and the
interesting part to a lot of writers is coming
up with the the character and the the person
that we're gonna go with on this journey and
coming up with those traits that will be fun to
write and this maybe the story goal just feels
a a thing that I have to figure out that I don't
really I'm not inspired by I'm that could be it
well I know off camera you mentioned the movie
Hustle and we both saw it and loved it is the
story goal the Adam Sandler goal or is the
basketball player's goal or are there several
story goals oh that's a good question so I when
I talk about the story goal I specifically mean
the protagonist story goal because that's really
what the movie is structured around that's the the
character wanting that thing is what gives you
that spine of the story that main through line
you might have heard it called so I would call
the story goal in in that movie Adam Sandler's
goal which if I were gonna articulate it I'm
not sure I remember all the details of it but
it was to have this basketball player be picked
up I'm not a sports person be picked up by a team
did that does that sound yeah I think it was
if I remember correctly was he scouting out
other players and nothing was panning out either
somebody was too old or whatever and then he sees
this guy at a street game if I remember yeah
and so it's this unexpected he gets his wish
and now he's got to convince this guy to come
to the states yeah so so if we're gonna kind
of look at that from the 40 000 foot view of of
the big picture of the story his story goal is
the thing he's trying to achieve by the end of
it and in that story I would say it's it that
story goal is formed after he meets that guy
so he is down on his luck he feels he's got
one last chance to make his career happen we're
talking about the Adam Sandler character sure
unexpectedly he sees this amazing Miracle of a
player and he's that's my chance if I can get that
guy a deal and I think initially it's a deal with
the team that he works for and then they go out on
their own or something that but if I can get that
guy a deal then basically my career will be saved
so that becomes his and again I wish I remembered
all the details of that story but I think that
that's it that becomes his story goal then that's
the thing that he's working towards for the rest
of the movie so the story goal isn't something
that the character starts the movie with it's
formed in act one so they start the story in their
normal world or their Ordinary World or whatever
and somewhere along the way in act one they
they form this story goal that is the thing
that drives the rest of the movie so then pursuing
that goal across act two and into act three and
then resolving it in Acts three that's that's the
rest of your movie and if I remember correctly I
think his back is against the wall because was
the initial coach or owner of the team a mentor
and then the dynamic changes and now there's a
a new person at the helm yeah and he's trying to
and he's not really fitting in well yeah so that's
part of the setup that that Ben Foster character
he becomes the team owner I think or something
that yeah yeah so he's the bratty son yes exactly
so the the mentor character Adam Sandler's Mentor
character was the owner he was the older the
patriarch of that family he passes away and then
the sun inherits it or inherits that role anyway
and he and Adam Sandler don't get along so then
that that you said it puts Adam Sandler's back up
against the wall and so then that's when he's in
in a tough place where he has okay I have one more
chance I've got one more chance to save my career
otherwise I'm done because those circumstances
chances have changed and then that's when he sees
the basketball player and forms that story goal
how does a writer create conflict well conflict is
created by two opposing forces so if we're talking
about the main conflict in a story that's the
protagonist trying to pursue their goal and then
whatever main force of opposition is getting in
their way so it could be well it can manifest in a
lot of different ways but it's whatever that main
thing is that's stopping the protagonist or not
allowing them to easily and quickly achieve that
goal yeah and it seems let's say with hustle which
we were talking about earlier the Adam Sandler
movie it's a pretty clear idea of what that
conflict is but if you look at let's say Forrest
Gump an older version of a movie it's not actually
that clear there's many things he's encountering
yeah and that's another reason that I would I
would call Forrest Gump a an advanced an advanced
craft story because it's pretty non-traditional
it's you have one guy and I don't know that I
would say he has a very clear end point that
he's working toward it's a little bit episodic
we're watching him go through history different
notable points in history and accidentally showing
up in the place at the wrong time or whatever
so that is a that's one of those stories that I
think would be a difficult one for a newer writer
to try to make work because if you don't have that
standard framework of character pursuing a goal
to give you that spine and that main conflict
to rely on then you have to use other tools in
your toolkit to create enough conflict and enough
engagement to keep us invested to keep us engaged
in the story and not checking out and turning it
off so I think Forrest Gump does that through just
the novelty of the character he's what's that guy
going to do next where is he going to show up and
what what famous moment in history are we going to
show it see him pop up in so I think that's part
of the appeal of that story and then also within
within each little segment of story I do think
that there is conflict it's not I'm saying that it
has no conflict but I think it happens in instead
of happening big picture across the whole movie
if I'm remembering it correctly it happens more
in self-contained segments and then you also have
these store these longer story lines of his love
for Jenny his relationship for Jenny which weaves
in and out of the other stuff that's happening if
if I'm remembering that yeah no that's excellent
and and then if you look at crash which I know we
brought up earlier that is nothing but conflict
yeah which is the through line of basically the
story that ties all the characters and different
stories together yeah so that one has so many I
think it has three or four intersecting storylines
and each one has its own main conflict that we're
following and then part of the appeal of that
too is seeing how those story lines intersect
because that's the the point of the story or the
concept of it how can goals of the protagonist and
antagonists oppose each other to create conflict
well there's a lot of different ways I think that
if you look at if you look at the movies that
you you'll you'll probably see that they the main
conflict falls into a few different categories
it's not always the same from movie to movie
sometimes the protagonist has a goal and the
antagonist is trying to stop them sometimes
the antagonist has a goal and the protagonist
is trying to stop them sometimes they both want
the same thing and so they're competing for a
prize or a thing that only one of them can have
and then sometimes they just happen to be the
protagonist and antagonist are just two characters
who each have a goal that happen to conflict with
each other so they're getting in each other's way
those are the ones that I've noticed are
the are the most common versions of that
sure and then if we go back to bridesmaids that
there is it seems all of them have a common goal
which is to be accepted amongst their peer
group yeah well if we're talking about the
story goal the more plot specific thing
that the protagonist is trying to achieve
so it's actually the antagonist is Helen which
is the The Rose Burn character and she wants
to take over our protagonist's friendship so
she's the the Rival for this best friendship
that Annie our protagonist has her lifelong
best friend so when Annie discovers that
about the Helen character that's when she forms
her goal to stop the antagonist so it's just it's
a little bit of it might sound very technical
or very Theory heavy but I think these are just
tools that help you understand your own story
and understand how your particular story works
so it's not that I'm I certainly don't mean that
you have four different types of conflict and you
have to use one of them I think if you if you've
come up with an idea that you're trying to develop
trying to look at it through these four types
of conflict or these four conflict Dynamics
if you can see that your conflict falls
into one of those categories it just helps
you understand oh okay so if mine is this then
that means it gives you it gives you a little
bit of guidance in terms of okay so that means
the antagonist has to come up with their goal
first so that then the protagonist can find
out about it and form her story goal and that
gives you a little bit of guidance in terms
of okay so that's the order that things need
to happen in so I can break down the plot of
my movie that way and it helps you write it so
and it seems in some films the antagonist
doesn't really turn out to be the antagonist
at all or maybe that's just how I'm seeing
it and then others it's clearly that was the
antagonist and they were defeated or they they win
whatever way so Silence of the Lambs we know that
definitely he's the antagonist but in in
Bridesmaids it's not maybe Helen is not
totally it's just that they both had their own
needs and they were just getting in the way yeah
and I think that that you can look at that too as
being appropriate to the tone or the style of what
you're writing because it might have felt weird
if Helen that antagonist was had seriously evil
designs on Annie and all that stuff so the humor
in that keeps it that that's also a guide in terms
of what types of conflict are going to work in
this so those two characters you probably have
a little bit more empathy for for Helen than you
do for Buffalo Bill you'd even though you learn
why he's doing what he's doing Helen is more of
a real character and the comedy comes from the
these wacky situations that our protagonist gets
herself into sure and we look at maybe Helen it's
more about vanity and serving her own ego and yeah
but but then you find out that actually she's very
empty and so it's not it's you feel for her in the
end yeah you want to hate her and then you realize
I don't actually hate you yeah they do a good
job actually of revealing that she is not the I
mean she is shallow and and focused on status and
and all that through the movie but they do reveal
that she has a an emotional need of her own she's
lonely and she's in an unfulfilling marriage and
so you end up growing I think to at least feel
for her if not her more by the end and she's
still the when we're talking about protagonist
and antagonist we're really just talking about
the mechanics of the story not necessarily that
she needs to feel a villain or a an evil character
or even that you can't her you can the character
who is the antagonistic Force we're just talking
about the the way the elements of the story work
together to create that that story engine or that
that spine of the story that we were talking about
earlier I think we spoke about this briefly in our
last interview but what are the four common
ways characters challenge protagonists oh
well I usually think about that in terms of
the supporting characters that are around the
protagonist and again I these are not not limited
to four there certainly could be many other ways
but I think that these are the patterns that I've
noticed a lot of times the supporting characters
will help the protagonist through conflict they
create some conflict with the protagonist but that
conflict or that pain that they're bringing into
the protagonist's life is one of those forcing
mechanisms that that force that protagonist to
grow and learn the lesson that they need to learn
so the four that I've noticed are I think I call
them aspirational models so giving your conflict
or sorry giving your protagonist a a model of what
they would to do or to achieve or to be and that
can create conflict because it creates a situation
where your protagonist is unhappy with where they
are and they're striving for more there's also
the cautionary tale so creating creating it's
almost the opposite of the of the other one where
it's showing your protagonist what could happen
if they continue down the road that they're on
so this is that that side character in and this
is such a minor minor role but in Crazy Stupid
Love that sad divorced dad at the bar that's a
cautionary tale he does not want to become that
guy so he's going to continue on striving to be
the womanizer that he's being groomed to
be because it's that that cautionary tale
it's a reminder to him and then there's
also I forget what I've labeled them but
you have the Mentor character or the person that
helps your character learn that they're capable or
they have it in them to do the thing that they're
trying to do and that doesn't always have to be a
nice Mentor it can be someone who pushes through
tough love or through conflict through challenging
your character but it's but the ultimate effect
is that it's forcing them to grow and to accept
that they are strong enough capable enough smart
enough whatever and then what's the fourth one
actually oh so a new world view oh yeah so that's
challenging the way your protagonist sees the
world so a lot of times the transformation that
your character goes through is is a is an it
starts internally and then it manifests externally
so sometimes there's a supporting character that
demonstrates the new way of thinking that maybe
ultimately your character will adopt or it
challenges their own way of thinking enough that
they grow and they make that change that they need
to make to have a new attitude about the world or
A New Perspective a new life philosophy that that
was the the point of the story that was the growth
that they needed at the beginning yeah so I think
in Bridesmaids is Melissa McCarthy the one scene
yeah so great so she gives her a kick in the pants
and and does it in a a sweet tough love way
yeah yeah that's a great scene so she comes
in and she's what did she say it's something
the world isn't gonna hand it to you you have
to go out there and take it the world's telling
you it's here to be taken or something that I
can't remember the exact words but but yeah she
she gives her that it's very funny but it's also
the exact tough love message that Annie needs
at that point sure and she's literally on the
couch not just metaphorically only touch she's
on the couch feeling sorry for herself and she's
I think she picks her up doesn't she even throw
her over her shoulder or something but yeah and
then with hustle I can't really remember I feel
there were Mentor characters that were helping
the Adam Sandler character yeah well what's
interesting I think in Hustle is that
you don't have to have a I guess archetypal
Mentor for this to for this role to come into play
any character or yeah any supporting character
that helps your protagonist along that Arc of
growth can can fill any of these roles so what's
great about hustle is those two guys it's really
their relationship they learn from each other
so even though they're not technically what I
would call a mentor to each other that's not their
role throughout the whole movie maybe in terms of
helping each of them grow and and get to the point
that they need to be in order to succeed in the
movie they do learn from each other the basketball
player learns that there's some people you can
rely on you can actually depend on someone they're
going to come through for you and I forget what
Adam Sandler learns from the basketball player
but it's I think it's complementary to that it's
if you keep trying keep working you can succeed
and not let people down or something that so
talking about that Melissa McCarthy
character quick quick point about that
what's great about that character is that that
speech she gives to Annie doesn't come out of
the blue so that was the last thing I wanted
to mention about her was that that character
has that world view from the beginning so she
Melissa McCarthy has that attitude about you go
out you grab life you you do it you take what you
want or you take the life you want you don't sit
back you don't sit on the couch and let it pass
you by if you want something you go out and you
try for it if you fail no big deal if you look
a fool no big deal but you you have to try in
order to get what you want and so I think if the
bad version of that relationship and that movie
would have been if Melissa McCarthy was just a
nice bridesmaid who came along at the moment in
the end to tell Annie what she needed to know
that would have felt unearned and tacked on
but because we saw that we didn't know where that
was going from the beginning but we saw that that
Melissa McCarthy character was that person all the
way through so when she delivers that message to
Annie when she needs it it makes sense it
feels emotionally true sure sure and just
going back to hustle real quick it seems also
too they both respect each other because they
know their families are very important to them
yeah and so I think they both have earned that
and they become almost mentors to each other
yeah in some ways yeah I think they do they
they because they each go into it I think with
certain preconceived notions about the other our
basketball player thinks that Adam Sandler's
just this Rich American who can he's got the
the wallet of the the team behind him and he
can do whatever and over time they learn they
learn how desperate each one is but they learn
what's really motivating each of them and they
bond over that because they each have a family
to you said each have a family to support they
learn that they each are on their this is this
is it this is the last chance that they have to
make this big thing happen so as those truths are
revealed about each of them it bonds them it makes
them grow closer which helps that partnership
and help helps them accomplish the thing yeah
what are Stakes something that confuses a lot of
a lot of writers it's so Stakes are very generally
whatever hangs in the balance with regard to what
your character is trying to achieve so a lot of
movies are very clear external life and death
Stakes if your character doesn't escape the serial
killer then they will die the your protagonist
will die so then it's life and death Stakes
so it's whatever consequence would would come and
would come to Bear if your protagonist fails to
achieve their story goal that's how I would define
it why are Stakes important well I think Stakes
are important because that's if if there's nothing
at stake then the story doesn't matter if if
your protagonist is trying to achieve a thing but
nothing there won't be any consequence to it then
I don't know if your audience will remain engaged
in the story because we we if we if we understand
that a series of events doesn't matter it doesn't
have any consequence to it it's inconsequential
I think most of us would check out could be
entertaining for a while but eventually we'll
be okay I I don't really care about the ending of
it so whatever's at stake in the story is really
what gets us to care about the outcome yeah and
I know again we use hustle as an example and I
think that's what got the film for me that's why
I liked it I'm not really into sports but the the
stakes that were involved and it was numerous
times yeah that was what was so great is you
thought you got through one hurdle and then there
was another one presented yeah and I think all of
these elements go hand in hand they all depend
on each other to create the effect that you want
them to create on the audience so what's great
about hustle is it it's not life or death Stakes
it's not that high stakes of a of a movie but
you feel so much for that character that what's
important to him is important to you so that
what this career means to him it's the only
thing he's ever done it's what he loves it's
what he's dedicated his whole life to there's
the feeling that if he washes out now his whole
life will be meaningless or he'll have invested
all this time and something that ultimately
didn't matter had no out no consequence so
all of that is wrapped up in what's at stake for
him so what I was describing earlier the external
Stakes of what's the consequence that will happen
if your character fails that's usually in a movie
there's something external at stake so life and
death Stakes or somebody's safety or losing the
house or what have you but then there's also the
internal Stakes of it the emotional Stakes of it
which is really what it means to your character so
it's important for the Adam Sandler character to
achieve that goal because of all that stuff that
it represents to him and that's that I think is
the more emotional side of things and that's what
really gets us emotionally invested in a story
I think there's one scene in the beginning or
close to it where Adam Sandler's on the phone
with someone he's 50 year old guys don't have
dreams we have nightmares and panic attacks yeah
yeah they do such a good job of layering that
stuff in of of just exactly what does it mean
if he fails to get this last career thing because
it would be very easy for that movie to hit all of
the the plot beats that we expect but to feel
empty that would have been the bad version of
that movie of a near retirement guy has one last
chance to get a player signed and you could see
that playing out in a way that the plot would
make sense but because they went the extra the
extra mile in terms of developing that character
and what it all meant to him that made it I loved
that movie it made it very emotional for me
instead of just being oh this is a fun movie
about guys playing basketball it was much more
about the Adam Sandler character and that was
a Redemption story for him it was my life hasn't
been a waste I'm not too old to accomplish things
all of those things I think were layered into that
movie and that's what made it that's what actually
I made it a movie that I would recommend to
people versus one that I watch and forget about
and and then without giving away too much the
basketball player has his own stakes and then
you also see that part of the stakes for Adam
Sandler is proving to the basketball player
that I'm I'm actually not going to let you down
yeah that's what was really great about that
movie too is that relationship between those two
guys so it's very much an underdog sports movie
and the two of them are the only the only two
the only person that each has in their life
that really believes in them in a way that that
matters and they can help each other and so there
are two underdogs working together to achieve this
big thing that nobody thinks they can achieve so
yes that that made me root for them what I love
that two underdogs working together that's yeah
yeah that's what works about it how do we know
the stakes are high enough for the audience to
be emotionally invested that's a good it's a good
question and I think that's one of those things
that's a little bit trial and error in your in
your writing you do what you can to create the
stakes in your story external and internal
try to plan them out in a way that that you
feel will be enough to get the audience invested
but that is definitely one of those things that
in completing the first draft sometimes you have
somebody read it they're I don't really understand
why this matters or I don't know why I should
care about this story and then that the stakes
aren't coming through they may be high enough
but they may just not be conveyed on the page
in a way that the whoever read it can understand
why they should care so there's both the aspect of
planning as you're developing your story thinking
through what's at stake and why this is going to
matter and what it means to the character and
so that's why the audience will care about it
thinking through all of those questions and and
making sure that's in your story that's half
the battle and then the other half is actually
figuring out how to put it on the page in a way
that your reader can pick it up and can understand
and can feel what's at stake yeah I think that was
what was my problem with bridesmaids when I heard
about it and it came out and everybody was raving
and I was turning on the radio and oh Bryce and
I'm oh another one of these female on female
hating each other and competing I don't want to
see that and it's it's not it's so well done and
there's you you really see okay no this is there's
a lot more layers to this yeah and actually you
bring you bring up a good point because seeing
Helen come through in the end and change a little
bit and seeing that she and Annie don't end the
movie totally at odds with each other I think that
that was really important to to the the overall
bigger picture of that movie which was it's not
about women competing against each other it's
actually about the female friendship and so even
the fact that the protagonist and antagonist
can come through the end of this experience
learning enough about each other to not hate
each other and not be working against each
other that was an important lesson in the movie
too can you help us understand the difference
between the stakes for the protagonist and the
antagonist oh sure I mean I think each character
needs to have something at stake we probably need
to understand what's at stake for the protagonist
a little bit more because we're entering
the story through that character and their
experience of it is really what we're tracking
and writing along with through the entire movie
so just in general I would say that the
protagonist Stakes are probably going
to be more developed both externally and
internally we're probably going to spend
more time understanding those Stakes establishing
them in the movie and then escalating them across
the movie but I do think that the antagonist
should have something at stake as well otherwise
I think that's when you get I mentioned
earlier you get maybe one of those movies
that hits certain plot beats but feels a
little bit empty if we don't understand why
the antagonist is doing what they're doing
as well even if it's in very broad Strokes
I think it can feel a little a little empty a
little cartoony or even a little bit it doesn't
have emotional logic sure the movie the the
book shop no okay yeah okay it was so good it
was with Patricia Clarkson who's this wealthy
woman who has started this art Society in her
town and then a new younger woman comes in and
opens up this bookstore and that causes Patricia
Clarkson's standing in the community like who is
this and you're doing this in my town I'm sorry
and then the young woman starts to put these
beautiful book displays and everybody comes in
and they love their books the bookstore and then
she does Lolita the book by navikov in the in the
window and that's Patricia Clarkson's in and
you will not have this in my town but really
her her motive is you won't show me up that that's
really what it's about and it's so well done and
it's it's about this you see each character's
Stakes one just wants to do it because I forgot
what the reason was she needed something in her
life and this gave her joy and then the Patricia
Clarkson it was more about her image and power and
yeah the two the two that well you bring up a good
point I haven't seen that movie I will add it to
my list but but I think you bring up a good point
which is when the conflict is more character
based or more emotional rather than physical
I think we probably need to develop the
stakes more in order to understand why
are these characters in Conflict why are
they taking the actions that they're taking
whereas if you have something very external very
actiony or horror movies are often high stakes
they're they're life and death situations but
because it's such an external physical conflict
we understand easily why this is important we
understand it's a life and death situation so
you don't really have to explain it as much
or develop it as much it's still useful I
think if even in movies that have very clear
external Stakes if you develop the internal
the meaning of it as well because that helps
us get more emotionally invested in the story
but yeah the I think the story that you brought
up that Bookshop is a good example of having
the conflict is really it's character based and
it's it's in not internal but it's it's not a
physical conflict between the two of them they
have these big emotional Stakes for each of them
they're standing in the town or their reputation
or whatever and so you have to develop those so
that the audience understands what's motivating
them to do the things they're doing because we
don't immediately understand why someone would
take those actions that they're taking in the
story what is the central dramatic question
well the central dramatic question is just
another way to phrase that idea that your
story is about one person trying to achieve
one thing so it's again it's another tool to
help you wrap your brain around your own story
so whatever your your protagonist is pursuing
their story goal over the course of that story
if you if you phrase that as a question that is
the central dramatic question and then that's
the question that you're trying to answer over
the course of the story so for for Silence of
the Lambs my go-to example it's it's will Clarice
catch the serial killer that's that's the question
that we're waiting for the answer to that the
story is hopefully going to answer by the end
of it otherwise we'll be unsatisfied what happens
when the central dramatic question is answered
then your movie's basically over so that that
gives us that framework for your story so it's
the thing that we're tracking and then once that
question is answered it feels to us your story is
resolved so there might be a little bit of wrap up
after that there might be some an emotional button
to put on the story or a subplot or something that
needs to be tied up or you might need a scene to
show us what's the character going to do next
where is their life going from here but pretty
much when that question is answered that's when
the audience feels ah okay this this thing that
I've been watching is now coming to an end
this is the end of it well if we look at a
lot of let's say tentpole movies there's probably
going to be a resolution unless there's a sequel
planned and then they want to keep you hanging
but some movies don't seem they always answer
they there's a there's a vagueness to them
yeah I don't I don't think an a movie has to
answer every question that it brings up but that
Central dramatic question we want some feeling of
resolution so I do think that there are movies
that leave it ambiguous and that's the point
but I think that it has to be clear that that is
the point so then we feel Okay so this experience
of exploring or trying to get the answer to this
question maybe we couldn't answer it and that's
the point of it and so that gives you that feeling
of even if the question isn't resolved that story
is resolved because we've gotten to a point
where we're ah okay so here's How This Ends we
don't know how that story is how that question is
answered so always know your audience is probably
much smarter than you give them credit for but
then if you end it in too much of a vague way it
may just be that the writer didn't have a clear
view themselves yeah I think in most cases even
if you leave it open if it's a a you don't fully
answer the question or you leave it an ambiguous
ending and that's the point of your story it has
to feel deliberate to your audience otherwise
they will feel you didn't do your job they'll
feel you left them hanging unintentionally and
I think you want you always want your audience to
feel they're in good hands you want them to feel
you are what you're doing and you're telling them
a very specific story in a very specific way and
the things that they're feeling were orchestrated
by you what I mean and so even if you don't give
them that nice tidy neat wrapped up thing in
the end they need to know that that was your
choice and not accidental what if the writer can't
figure out what the central dramatic question is
well I I don't think that there's necessarily
one answer that you're you have to figure out
exactly what that question is otherwise your
story doesn't work again it's more of a tool
to help you and give you a framework for your
story and understand what your audience is
tracking in the story so it's a way
to get everybody on the same page
but I think just thinking about what is my
protagonist trying to achieve by the end of this
answering that question of who
wants what in this story and then
turning that into a question is the way you
get your central dramatic question so it's
knowing what your audience sorry it's knowing
what you want your audience to track that's
the question that you're that you're trying
to pose by the end of act one if that makes
sense well can we have examples of central
dramatic questions in different films sure so
I think the central dramatic question in Crazy
Stupid Love would be actually I think in that
movie it's it's something along the lines of
what guy will Cal decide to be it's because he's
at a Crossroads in his life where he's been asked
for a divorce he doesn't know I think that he even
says he doesn't know who he is as a father and as
a husband and that's part of being misguided by
the Ryan Gosling characters Cal's at a loss he's
adrift and he doesn't know which direction to go
now that his life as he knows it is ending and
so I think that if I'm remembering it the central
dramatic question in that movie is what what guy
will cat or what man will Cal choose to be and so
we see him navigate that question over the course
of the movie he gets taken One Direction by Ryan
Gosling and then around the middle of the movie he
realizes oh this isn't this isn't who I want to be
or this isn't doing any favors it's not getting me
the thing that I ultimately want which is my wife
so again I'm not 100 sure that I'm remembering
that movie correctly but I think that you could
look at it that way that that's the question where
we're waiting for him to answer by the end of it
sure and and can he still be a good guy despite
bad things happening to him and show that at
the core he's actually a great person yeah
and it's part of his character Arc too of
choosing ultimately the lesson I think that he
learns in that movie is the thing that he says
when he stands up in front of his son's middle
school graduation where he's when you find the
one you don't give up you keep fighting for them
so that's the guy that he's decided he's going to
be by the end of the movie is he's he's not going
to be this womanizer who goes out and sleeps with
every woman he can he knows who he's in love
with he knows what he wants is to to have that
relationship and so he's just gonna keep trying
so even if you don't know the outcome you keep
trying for the one that you that you really love
so that's the lesson that he learns at the end of
it and then for Silence of the Lambs yeah so that
one's a lot more straightforward you have a nice
clear external goal in that one so the central
dramatic question there is is Will Clarice catch
the serial killer because that's everything
that's set up and give the context that we're
given in act one is you have Clarice you have a
serial killer on the loose she's the only one or
she's she's one person who has a special in to
get help to catch that serial killer so that's
the goal that's formed by the end of act one is
I'm going to try to catch that serial killer so
if we just turn that into a question it's will
she catch that serial killer and that is what
the audience is watching and waiting for the
answer to and then to go back to the Forrest
Gump example I know we're using it a lot but that
one it seems there that's a little unclear to me
yeah and and again I haven't seen that movie in
so long that I'm not 100 sure on how everything
plays out in it but it does feel to me that is a
much more episodic story I wonder if I re-watched
it if and again there are moments that I remember
out of it but I don't remember the whole story I
wonder if the Jenny relationship is actually
the spine of that story and so it could be
again I'd be guessing but it could be that the
the central dramatic question has something to
do with whether he'll have a relationship with
her but again I'm not 100 sure on that one why do
you put the central dramatic question in between
act one and act two oh well if we look at the the
basic structure of a movie we typically talk about
it in three-act structure and that's really just
how the pursuit of the goal breaks down so in act
one because really the the story of your movie is
the story of this the goal and the pursuit of
this goal that's what creates the through line
in your story so act one that goal is created
act two the goal is pursued and then act three
it's resolved or not so they get the goal or they
don't so that the central dramatic question is
basically by the end of act one we have all of the
context that we need in order to understand what
the protagonist is trying to do and what they're
trying to do is answering that question so that's
why the central dramatic question is solidified
or asked for the audience at the end of act one
and then the meat of the movie is watching them
try to answer it across act two and act three
what is the purpose of act one well act one
gives us all of the context that we need in
order to understand the story that we're about to
watch and understand it basically sets up the who
wants what of of your movie so if we look at each
movie as being a story of someone wants something
wants it badly goes after against
big conflict great opposition
then act one sets up all of those pieces so it
tells us who it tells us what they want it tells
us why they want it and it tells us what they're
up against so all of those pieces that create
the foundation of the story or that story engine
that we were talking about earlier that's what act
one does it sets up all of those things so that
when we launch into Act 2 or that act 2 Adventure
you might have heard it called when we begin that
we have all of the information that we need in
order to understand who are we watching what
are they trying to do what are they up against
why do they want it so badly all of that's been
established so that we can just watch everything
escalate in act two does that make sense it does
and so as we talked about earlier a lot of people
have a great idea and maybe the act one is really
strong but then subsequent acts seems it's very
murky and that's where the outline would help them
yeah and I think just knowing that act one is is
set up it's where you set up all of that context
and then understanding that act 2 is escalation so
you have all those pieces in place in act one and
then act two is just playing with them and forcing
them to butt up against each other and create
bigger and bigger conflicts and higher and higher
Stakes that's where that's the fun of act two is
watching how everything that you've set up in Act
One watching how that blossoms now how or explodes
what mistakes do writers often make in Act One
well I think the the probably big bucket maybe a
lot of different things fall into this but the the
main thing is not setting up all of the context
that we need so not clearly establishing those
those Foundation pieces of the story those main
elements that we need to understand and appreciate
act two so it's the protagonist it's their story
goal it's where the conflict is coming from that
main conflict or the antagonist and it's the main
thing that's at stake for the protagonist so all
of those pieces have to be in place in act one and
when when they're not properly established I mean
I think that's the that's the most common
mistake that that writers make in act one
what mistakes do writers make in act two oh Act 2
is so wide open it's it's the escalation of your
story and it's watching the thing that you've
set up it's watching it play out but it can go
in so many different directions I think maybe if
I had to name one thing probably the biggest would
mistake would be no I have to I have to do too
so the first one is not having their protagonist
pursue the goal consistently and urgently because
that's really what moves your story forward is the
protagonist trying to achieve that thing so that's
a big one and then I would say maybe the other big
one and this is connected is not escalating
things so hitting the same note over and over
not intensifying the conflict not raising
the stakes because we want things to to
grow we want the conflict to double back on
itself and compound and things to get harder
and more intense and to feel more important
and more urgent for the protagonist that's the
progression of act two should should have that
building feeling to it and so I think that's
probably the other the other big one is maybe
hitting the same the same intensity level or re
reworking the same conflict without making things
harder or making things more important or urgent
yeah that was the great thing about hustle is that
so many new things came up without spoiling it for
those who haven't seen it once you got through
one hurdle a new one was presented yeah and it's
really not even until the end where I mean you're
this can't end this way but anyway yeah and that
was they they did such a good job of having
conflict come from so many different directions
too it wasn't just that this is a difficult thing
to achieve and so it's Adam Sandler trying to get
the basketball player in shape or ready to
compete at this level you had other players
with their own agendas you had the we talked about
the owner has his own agenda things going wrong so
you had conflict coming from all these different
directions which is great because again growing
the intensity across act two that's what keeps
you leaning in over and over again going oh no
what's gonna happen now what's what could possibly
go worse for this character and and that keeps you
reinvesting in the outcome I don't know if you've
seen did you watch the series made oh absolutely
yes yes so that is such a good example just
even the first episode of that series is such
a good example of conflict and building conflict
and nothing going for the protagonist one of the
comments I think that writers hear a lot is things
are too easy for your protagonist or you need to
increase the conflict or make things hard put your
character through hell those are all tidbits of
advice that writers hear but I feel writers their
characters sometimes and don't want to make things
too hard or or don't see a way for the character
to get through it if they make things too hard
but that that first episode of made was such a
good example of nothing went for that character
every single thing went wrong and she still I mean
that's the point is that makes us root for her
even more because it everything's stacked against
her and we're we're on board we're watching we
want her to succeed so I don't think you can
ever make things too hard for your protagonist
and and that was one of the things in listening
to the audiobook that it was based on it was so I
felt so bad for this woman and and hearing it and
then I guess it was just easier for me to watch it
play out and and I don't know it was still
difficult but yes I mean it was so many
different things being set up I don't want to
give that away but yeah I absolutely love that
yeah I think that's a great one for writers to
watch if if you ever you've ever gotten the note
of you're not making things hard enough on
your character watch that and see just how
hard you can you can be on your character without
breaking them because I think maybe that's what
scares writers is if I make things too hard I
won't be able to figure out how they're gonna
keep going or I won't be able to figure out how
to get them through it but that dialing up that
intensity is is good it's good for your
story and that's what your audience wants
sure and she would have these meltdowns and
then she would get back on the horse and then
new things would happen yeah and we her more
for that too for not giving up so yeah she
was very likable yeah as a character what is the
purpose of act three well act three is to resolve
that question that you've asked or that main
conflict that you've put your character into
so it's really it's to resolve the the
question that we've been exploring over
the over the course of the movie when you set
up all those pieces that we talked about in act
one all of the foundation pieces of your story
and then we watch them play out across act two
act three is where you answer that Central
dramatic question wrap up your story resolve that
conflict if you want to think of it that way it's
it's basically basically The Resolution Act that's
you've done all the escalations and there will
still be some escalations in act three but it's
building toward resolving your your main conflict
and answering that Central dramatic question what
mistakes do writers make most often in act three
well I think the big one maybe the most obvious
one would be just not resolving that Central
dramatic question or that main conflict that we're
we're we're watching the movie to understand
how that's going to wrap up and so I think
not resolving that is is maybe the the biggest
or the most common newer writer mistake
sometimes sometimes newer writers again
out of fear maybe that their story is
getting boring or they don't know how to
how to escalate it and don't know where
to go from here they they take a left turn
and start tracking a different question or
a different conflict that their protagonist
engages in and we really want act three to
complete that through line not take such a hard
left that we're now watching a different movie
and does that often we see comments underneath the
trailer oh the trailer is better than the movie
is it often the act three do you think or the act
two or there's no hard and fast rule yeah I wonder
I I don't know for sure but I would I would guess
that maybe a really good trailer was cut from from
a movie that didn't have as much going on in act
two and probably act three as well but since Act
2 is really the movie that's what the movie is
it's the character trying to do this thing it's
conflict escalating it's Stakes raising that's
really the act two and that is the movie that
we're we're there to see so I would imagine if if
a trailer or if a movie is getting those comments
and the trailer was so much better than the movie
The Good interesting or entertaining moments were
cut into the trailer and maybe there just wasn't
enough going on in the movie to sustain interest
or to to maintain our our investment in
the outcome of it why is transformation
of the main character important well I think
we go to movies really to see transformation
transformation means that the story had an effect
it the series of events that you've watched it had
some consequence it had an effect on the character
that went through them so that's one reason and
then I think also even if nobody talks about it
this way we we look for that transformation as
a inspiration or you could call it a guide for for
living a good life it's this person went through
this experience and came out the other side can
give you hope it can give you a little bit of
a guide a guide on how to live and be a better
person but that's what gives the story meaning
in the end how does transformation relate to theme
well I think that most often we see the theme of
the movie through the character's transformation
so whatever that lesson is that they learn
from going through this whole experience
that's basically the theme of your movie
the the theme is the organizing principle of
your story and everything connects to the theme
and everything falls under the umbrella of the
theme and the way your movie plays out proves
the theme to the audience and so a big part of
that is the way the protagonist goes through the
story and what happens to them how they transform
because of what they've gone through so we see
the theme the meaning or that takeaway message
of the story we see that through the way the
character transforms most often for some reason
I'm thinking of Goodwill Hunting just popped into
my mind it's been many years since I've seen
it yeah the transformation of that character
yeah and the theme would be what just I know you
said host earlier yeah well I think that it themes
tend to fall into a couple of categories or
patterns one of them can be Hope for living
and then another category I think is there's
Beauty in the struggle themes fall into these
different categories but specific themes for
particular movies most often I look to the
characters transformation or the lesson that
they learn to understand what the theme is
in Goodwill Hunting it's been a while since I
saw that movie but I guess let's see how does he
transform from the beginning to the end well so
he's he's angry he gets in fights he's got this
job that he's looked down on a pawn but he's
definitely smarter than and maybe some of the
students around him there and he [Music] meets
a girl yeah I was gonna say I think the lesson
has to do with that big choice that he makes
at the end so he he learns over the course of
this story that he's not doing himself or anyone
else any favors by not living up to his potential
again it's been a while since I saw the movie so
hopefully that's accurate but but I would say that
that if you look at his transformation and the
key lesson that he needs to learn or that he does
learn by the end of that story then that's the
key to your theme I would say that that lesson is
basically the theme you could reword it a little
bit and then if if that's accurate say for for
Goodwill Hunting if the lesson that he learns
is life is about living up to your potential
for example I don't know if that's true but we'll
say that that's the lesson he learns in Good Will
Hunting I would say that the theme of the movie
would be very close to that so the overall message
that that story would send that you would maybe
walk away from the movie understanding is living
up to your potential is what life's about or it's
how to live a good life is to to try to strive to
live up to your potential or what have you what
does the audience need to see in each Act in order
to understand the protagonist transformation
oh well I think the the transformation has
it has an arc of its own so in the same way
that the plot has a setup and a build and a
resolution I think the characters Arc also has
those those parts so in act one we need to set
up that Arc by understanding what the character
needs what is their deficit or what lesson do
they need in their life what are they doing wrong
or how are they seeing the world in a way that's
not serving them and what effect is it having
on their life so we need to see that they need
a lesson and we need to see we need to understand
that they do need it and usually that's by seeing
some negative effect that not understanding that
lesson is having on their life and then in act two
that's where we see the the the story of this Arc
play out so we need to see the things that he the
protagonist experiences in the story forcing him
along that growth Arc forcing him to realize the
lesson that he needs to get closer to accepting
it or to maybe the character is resisting learning
this lesson and the things that he's going through
are forcing him closer and closer to that breaking
point where he's going to finally understand what
he needs to learn from this whole this whole mess
so act two forces the the plot events and
the experiences that the character has
forces him closer to understanding the lesson that
thematic lesson and then in act three that's where
we get to see the character Embrace this lesson
or not in most movies that we watch that have
Transformed Characters and Happier Endings
usually they accept the lesson and embrace it
and incorporate it into the way they approach the
world and then that's that's how we see that Arc
resolve how does character lead to plot oh well I
think you can you can use character to lead you to
figure out plot by related to character Arc so
understanding what lesson your character might
need to learn or what transformation you want this
character to have this is coming at it from a a
meaning point of view instead of an external plot
point of view so coming from inside the story to
figure out the plot so if you start with character
and you think about what lesson do I want this
character to learn or what transformation can
I imagine this character going through that
interests me that can lead you to plot because
that the plot that they experience needs to
create that change in the character those events
have to force that character to learn that lesson
so you can reverse engineer the plot from the
transformation that the character is going through
thinking about okay here's the transformation that
interests me I'm I'm curious about a character who
maybe goes from being an independent single
guy who's determined not to have any any ties
or or serious relationships to being someone
who is is committed and surrounded by close
relationships with friends and family so
that's his transformation just for example
if you're interested in a character that makes
that transformation then you can reverse engineer
the plot to think about well what events would
force somebody to make that change to learn that
lesson and transform in that way do you see
that from time to time with new writers that
there's not a real lesson that that's that's
learned with their character and then having
to go back and rework it yeah I I do because I
think that not all not all the time but a lot of
newer writers and not even newer writers a lot of
Writers come that story from interesting plot from
interesting what if situations that are cool or
fun and then developing the character to go to go
along with it and there's certainly nothing wrong
with that I I think about story in that way too A
lot of the time but I think for newer writers
then the challenge is understanding that the
the transformation or the character development
side of the story is is still needed is important
and we talked about earlier that writing
a screenplay is really getting a handle on
lots of different skills it's a bunch of different
skill sets that you have to employ all at the same
time and I think character development tends to be
one that maybe not for not as forgotten but gets
pushed to the side because the plot is the thing
that you need to have in order for your story
to for your movie to begin and eventually end
that you have to work out the steps of the plot
but character you can have characters show up
on the page and go through this plot without
making a change and you've still written you
can still write a complete screenplay that way
so then that's another skill set to master
I think or to to learn about and so yes
with newer writers I think a lot of times not
not even a lot of times but often you'll see
a complete story and the story is there and
maybe they know that the character should
learn something across the the course of the story
but they haven't fully gotten every step of that
transformation worked out in there sure so maybe
too worried about just how the overall story is
and then not really seeing this change in the
character at the end yeah and I think that for
again because it's so many skill sets it's it's
not even it's it's certainly not deliberate of
oh I'm not going to worry about character
and it's also not I guess it's a very easy
thing because you're trying to juggle so many
moving Parts when you write a screenplay that
it's I totally understand and not not maybe doing
all of the character development up front that you
could so it's just part of the rewrite process you
you go through it many times and then hopefully
you get the character there too yeah hence the
second set of eyes yeah yeah exactly you said
there's so many skill sets to writing a screenplay
can you just clarify what some of those skill sets
are yeah I just think it's we usually think about
writing a screenplay as just it's just one thing
it's one story that I'm putting down on paper
but when you when you try to write a screenplay
well you probably eventually realize that there's
understanding structure there's understanding plot
and how to escalate conflict there's understanding
character and character development theme and how
theme works with transformation and that's just
big stuff and then you also think about the on
the page craft writing action lines well writing
dialogue well there's all these little not little
but there are all these different skill sets
that go into making a really good screenplay
and I think it's a lot more than writers realize
maybe at first when they come at writing a script
because you you you have an idea and you love
your story idea and you start putting it down
on paper and that's great I think that's the way
the best way to learn is to through experience and
through trying it but eventually I think anyone
who's written a script or two realizes oh this
is this is harder than I realized it was going to
be because there are so many different things that
I have to be good at in order to make the whole
thing good so if someone just erases a paragraph
on page 68 it's going to change things maybe
on page 10 that they didn't oh wait a minute
I just realized if I do that that's a
major thing I have to then go back yeah
for sure everything's interdependent
and I think also this is what this
is what makes the rewriting process so
fun and so challenging is that because
you can be good at one thing or have one thing
figured out one area one skill set or whatever
worked out and still be struggling with other
areas and because they're related they they
will probably affect each other or a lot of
times we were just talking about character
gets short-shrift while we're trying to work out
the plot because we're there's so much to think
about in how do I structure this plot and how do
I escalate the conflict and how do I make sure
that there it's logical from beginning to end and
so then in the rewrite you're gonna have to bring
that character development to the front of your
mind and pay attention to it as you're rewriting
it but yes everything's interdependent and I
think even when you have some of those skill sets
really worked out you the plot's great or whatever
when one of them isn't working say the character
development or say the dialogue you just haven't
paid attention to and it needs a lot of work
it it just it you realize how much work goes
into a screenplay how many different skill
sets you need in order to complete that thing
in a way that can be appreciated as a whole
can you explain the Blake Snyder beat sheet
sure so Blake came up with this idea of the
15 beats that make up any story he put them on a
beat sheet it's become famous now for is a great
tool for people who are developing a story idea
I think or trying to learn about story structure
so the one I will say the one thing that I think
people who are introduced to the beat sheet maybe
Overlook and then have to learn later so this
is a shortcut is that some of the beats are
turning points and then some of the beats are
sections of the story so I'll I'll go over them
but it's useful to note that because
I think that's one of the things
that confuses people when they're
trying to learn about the 15 Beats
okay so the opening image is the first image of
your screenplay or of your movie it sets the tone
establishes when and where we are in the world so
the world of your story the next beat that shows
up on the beat sheet is the theme stated and Blake
Snyder wrote in Save The Cat I think the theme
stated shows up on page five of your screenplay
it's the theme is usually the guiding principle
or the the big idea of the story what it's really
about behind the plot and behind the characters
and he liked to say that it was stated somewhere
in the story or on page five of your screenplay
it was stated outright usually in a line of
dialogue by one of the characters the next
beat on the on the beat sheet is the setup and
that's one of those beats to pay attention to
because the setup is actually a section of
the screenplay so it's not just one page or
one scene it's a whole section I think he notes
that it the setup is page one to page 12 or so
and so that's introducing us to the main
character and with their Ordinary World
or their normal World where they are in their
life now before the story gets started and one
of the things he wrote about in Save The Cat was
that you can use the idea of at home at work and
at play to introduce your protagonist so seeing
them in these different aspects of their their
normal World gives us a sense of who they are the
next beat on the beat sheet is the Catalyst and
that is a beat that should be more of a turning
point one scene or One Moment In Your screenplay
the catalyst is also something that other people
refer to as the inciting incident it's really the
event that kicks the story into motion sometimes
you can think of it as the why now of the story
it's this event throws your protagonist world into
disarray or forces them into action by creating
some problem or opportunity for them that they
have to take advantage of that they have to deal
with and that's how it starts the story into
motion the next beat is the debate section and
again it's a it's a section of the screenplay
so this isn't just one scene I keep emphasizing
that because I've seen writers get confused and
when they're trying to outline their stories they
get to the debate section and they they put
in one scene and then when they go to write
the screenplay they don't have enough story to
fill out the pages so the debate section is where
is that section in between the Catalyst or the
inciting incident kicking the story into motion
and your protagonist deciding what to do about it
so there's that debate section in between there
where we really try to close all of the obvious
doors for your protagonist and funnel them toward
this main thing that they're going to do over the
course of the story I also to look at the debate
section as getting the audience on board so you
tell us what's at stake for the protagonist why
they have to do this thing because usually the
thing that they're going to do in act two is
this big audacious crazy scary dangerous thing so
the debate section use that to get the audience
on board and show us why do they need to do this
thing why is it so important what happens if they
don't do it help us understand what the potential
consequences are so that we have that tension of
wanting them to do it but being a little bit
worried about them before they go into act two
so the next beat is the break into act 2. so at
the end of the debate section after you've gone
through all of that gotten the audience on board
shown us why the character has to do this thing
the break and act 2 is the turn in your plot where
you send the protagonist into Act 2 onto that Main
Adventure pursuing that story goal engaging
in the main conflict however you want to look
at it that's where that's what the break
into Act 2 does the next section is the
B story then the next beat is the is the B story
so Blake liked to say that after that main or that
after that major plot point of the break into act
two it was a good time to give your protagonist
and your audience a little bit of a breather
and introduce a subplot he talked about the B
story being the relationship or the subplot where
your character could discuss learning the theme
so a lot of times it'll be it might be a romance
or it might be a friendship or something but it's
giving your character an opportunity to talk about
what he's learning talk about what he's going
through and what he's learning from it the next
beat on the beat sheet is fun and games and again
this is a section of the story so the fun and
games is actually on the beat sheet it's all of
the first half of act two so it's it's basically
everything after the break into two up until the
midpoint which we'll get to in a sec but so the
fun and games Blake wrote that it was the is where
we see the promise of the premise so whatever the
concept is of your story the thing that's hooky
and intriguing about this story that's where we
see it come to fruition is in the fun and game so
I think his famous examples are Liar Liar
it's where we see Jim Carrey getting used
to not being able to tell a lie or in Legally
Blonde it's where we see L getting acclimated
to Harvard Law and she's very much a fish out of
water so that's fun in game stuff you can also
think of it as trailer moments those those very
entertaining and very on concept moments or scenes
that you would probably cut into a trailer to show
somebody what's so entertaining about your movie
the next beat is the midpoint so that's the
middle of your story the midpoint is a is a
more of a moment or a scene instead of a section
so again just making that distinction but the
midpoint can be a few scenes in a row it's
not really a section of your screenplay but
it can be a sequence because usually it's a big
set piece or an action sequence or something
that is a little bit bigger than other scenes
and really the function of the midpoint is to
increase the opposition and or raise the stakes
of your story so basically what it comes down to
is the midpoint is increasing the tension in your
story to give it more momentum to get through the
second half so sometimes it turns the story in an
entirely New Direction but doesn't always have to
in any case what it does is it it increases that
that tension feeling so that it's winding up a
toy and letting it go so it gives us that extra
momentum and energy to get through the second
half of the story then after the midpoint the next
beat on the beat sheet is the bad guys close in
so Blake liked to say that this is where things
really start going wrong for your protagonist
so you can have both external and internal bad
guys so it can be plot stuff is going wrong the
literal bad guys can be closing in getting closer
gaining on your protagonist but it can also be
emotional stuff they're really struggling
with what they're doing they feel they
can't succeed and maybe they're having
a crisis of Faith or of confidence
and then you can also have conflict within the
protagonist team so that's also causing things
to fall apart and basically the bad guys close
in section is leading us downhill towards the
next couple of Beats which are the All Is
Lost and Dark Night of the Soul Beats and
these are separate beats on the beat sheet but I
to talk about them together because they really
are complementary and they work together to
create that low point at the end of act two
so I I to think of them as one is more external or
plot focused and one is more internal or character
focused the All Is Lost is usually the what I
think of as the plot focused one where it's it
looks the character the protagonist is not going
to succeed it you might think of it as he's as
far away from his goal as he'll ever be or he
feels he's failing he feels there's no hope
he doesn't know how he's going to keep going
on and try to get that goal and then the Dark
Knight of the soul is the emotional reaction to
that other things that can happen at the All Is
Lost can be the death of a mentor I think this
is where Blake wrote that there's that whiff
of death so it can be the loss or death of a
mentor or of a friend or of a support system
it can be a major setback being exposed to the bad
guy so now they know who who they're up against or
it can be losing an advantage but you want it to
be pretty big because we're talking about the big
turning points of the story and then the darkener
the soul is the emotional reaction to that so
it's now that this big setback has happened or it
looks I'm not going to be able to achieve my goal
the protagonist sitting in that for a
moment and wondering what do I do from here
and a lot of times that's where they have a
glimmer of I finally understand the lesson
of the theme I finally understand what I
should be learning from this experience
they they're not always ready to embrace
that lesson at that point yet but they're
starting to understand oh this is what
all of this has been trying to teach me
and then after that the next beat is the break
into Act 3. so that's the major turning point
where we go from Act 2 to act three and basically
it's the beginning of the resolution section of
the story so that turn you usually want it to feel
it's pushing us in a new direction that is toward
however the story is going to resolve so your
character your protagonist might have a new plan
so after that Dark Night of the Soul moment they
might have a moment of inspiration where they're
oh okay now I know what I what I need to do I now
I know how to defeat this bad guy and so the break
into three is where they begin that that final
push to resolve that story that main conflict or
however you want to think about that that story
so the next beat on the beat sheet after the
break into act 3 is the finale and this is the
section that most people forget is a section of
the story instead of one scene so your finale or
the way Blake wrote about the finale is that the
finale was all of act three so it's what you would
call the resolution or he called it the finale
so this is where we see that new plan that your
protagonist has play out or we see them execute
that that final push toward trying to resolve
the main conflict so finale all of act three
I think that is that is that beat 14 and then
there's 15 is the final image okay so the last
beat on the beat sheet is the final image
so that's after the finale has played out
we've seen how the main conflict has resolved
we've seen if the protagonist has achieved his
goal if they've succeeded or failed how the
out how the story ends basically what is the
final outcome and then we have the very last beat
which is the final image which is that you might
think of it as almost the aftermath of the of the
finale it's now that the story is over give us
one final scene or image or moment to send the
audience out feeling how you want them to feel
knowing maybe what the character is going
to do next or if you need to recalibrate the
the emotion at the end of your story maybe the
maybe the the end of the finale was a big action
sequence and you want to leave us feeling knowing
that your protagonist is okay and he won and he's
safe and he's rested and not injured anymore or
something that the final image can can do that
Blake also liked to write that it was the final
image is a bookend for the opening image so I
think some people look at it as you want the
the change or the contrast between the opening
image and the final image to be big enough to
show that there was a transformation in that
in that story so we went from point A to point
Z and there's a big enough contrast there that
we can see this story covered some ground and
had some consequence to it if that makes sense.